foreign
[Music]
let's go back to 15 plus 10. that is our
Standard Time control
and we're playing Wang to I think is a a
stream regular we've played them before
to those watching on YouTube I'd like to
quickly apologize that the videos
recently have been coming out with uh a
slightly bigger Gap uh this is for no
dark reason it's just because I've been
teaching at a lot of camps I went to
Norway so I'm super super busy right now
IRL
um and I'll do my best to come back to
regular content making you know every
two days uh very very soon I have one
more camp in Atlanta that I'm teaching
at this coming week and then the moment
it's over uh things kind of settle down
and I'll be able to come back to a more
more regular routine appreciate the
patience
and I do not appreciate the opening that
we are facing the London system I don't
recall if we Face the London thus far in
the speed run believe it or not I think
we have not like I just don't remember
um I just don't remember us facing it
and
the thing about the London is that it's
it's less important what what you play
with black against it and more important
that whatever it is that you choose to
play you know really well there are a
million systems that you can play with
black
which system you choose largely depends
on your style there are more aggressive
ways to play there are more balanced
ways to play but there is one system
that I recommend to everyone who who
wishes to make London system players
uncomfortable
and uh who wants to get a dynamic
unbalanced and relatively speaking
non-theoretical game and all of this
starts with the move C5
and this is the most combative response
against the London for obvious reasons
we're immediately challenging White
Center this isn't really a pawn
sacrifice we'll do a little theoretical
examination after the game
and I will say as a disclaimer I'm not
too proficient uh in the theory of the
system in OTB games against good players
I've mostly played the king's Indian
setup but I really really like C5 and
rapid and Blitz
if white takes on C5 typically black
plays Knight A6 and immediately is able
to reclaim the pawn with interest white
plays one of several possible moves
which is of course
uh E3
and now you can play D5 which transposes
into what we can call the Main Line the
most popular continuation
but the way to deviate
uh from mainstream theory is to quickly
position Our Queen on B6 and we can do
it immediately
but I like first taking on D4 creating a
pawn structure imbalance
this creates an imbalance because it
leads to a situation where white as a
three on two on the queen side and black
actually has I don't say this very often
a five on four in the center and on the
king Side Pawn structure imbalances
create Dynamic play they create the
possibility for tactics and this is
already a step forward when you're
dealing with a London system player and
now we position Our Queen on B6 now if
you've seen London Games whatever you
play with black against it you've
probably seen the queen come out to this
Square in the London system it's a very
very typical development of the queen
because on B6 it does a lot of things
it's out of the way of the other pieces
but most importantly it's pressuring two
pawns at once and this is as primitive
as this sounds a drawback of the London
system when the bishop comes out this
early the B2 Pawn is left without a
Defender and white actually has a pretty
difficult time finding a defensive move
which doesn't make serious positional
concessions and the move that a lot of
less experienced players play here
automatically is B3 we might face it in
this game but the move B3 comes at a
great positional cost First of all it
doesn't develop a piece but most
importantly it tremendously weakens the
dark squares on the Queen's side C3 B4
A3 bonds don't go backwards so the move
B3 which I'll talk about after the game
is a common response which I I think
already gives black a very comfortable
game Knight to C3 along with the sister
move Knight to A3 is the most
challenging the most principled response
to Queen to B6
the idea is simple if we grab this Pawn
this leads to a very theoretical line we
are not going to go into it white plays
Knight to B5 with very very dangerous uh
consequences for black there is a ton of
computer Theory there I don't know what
the current modern evaluation is but I'm
pretty sure that you're not supposed to
take the pawn I'm pretty sure that even
if we play all the engine moves with
black white actually has a very strong
initiative there we'll explore some
lines just out of curiosity but this is
not the move that I recommend there are
a couple of possibilities here
um one is to play D5 and contest the
center I don't love D5 because white can
play the move Knight to B5 and force our
Knight to occupy a very awkward Square
on A6 this also happens in the jababa
London because then we'll not never
really be able to get rid of the snipe
will be completely Frozen on the queen
side what are the other possibilities we
can put the pawn on D6 and we can play
this sort of King's Indian style we can
play D6 and then G6 and play all the
king's Indian moves and the good thing
about that setup is that we've forced
the Knight onto C3 and typically with
white in King's Indian positions you
want to have D4 C4 included and then the
other option is to play A6 I've
recommended this to some people this
covers the B5 Square it's actually a
very challenging move and typically A6
is paired with D5 so choose your pick I
want to go A6 because it is the least
explored of all the possibilities most
of the time even pretty good players
like 2000s are are completely on their
own at this point and that is exactly
what we want I think this is a very
underrated system
we will check with the newest stockfish
I haven't analyzed this properly in a
couple of years
white has an edge if white plays this
absolutely perfectly but very very few
people do and even if he does you get a
combative interesting Dynamic game
ultimately this is what you want
um if you're
not a grand master if you're not a 2700
your your primary objective out of the
opening isn't to get 0.00 right that's
the mistake a lot of players make it's
to get a comfortable position in a
position that you know makes your
opponent uncomfortable okay Rook to B1
so our opponent defends the pawn without
weakening all of the dark squares still
it's nice that we've garnered a Tempo
and forced white to play this kind of
somewhat awkward move
okay so once again we can play D6
there's nothing wrong with that but then
why did we play A6 right then A6 becomes
a waste of time so let's play this more
consistently let's go D5
let's see how our opponent chooses to
develop their pieces
and there's a lot of positional
subtleties here that newer players might
kind of rule their eyes at and might
find a little bit over their heads but
once again I want to remind you that the
whole concept of the speed run is that
most of my advice is based on is is
aimed at the level where I'm currently
located
um and I'll still try to explain things
in very general terms for newer players
Knight F3 as far as I know is an
inaccuracy believe it or not this
unbelievably natural developmental move
is a serious positional and accuracy who
can explain why and first and forem what
is the move what does it allow
what does it allow and you might even
object to the use of the word Allah what
does it mean it allows something because
we're just developing our pieces what it
allows is Bishop to G4 and why am I
using the word Allahu in this context
Bishop G4 is actually a very unpleasant
move I'll show you an analog in the Karo
Khan where something very similar
happens the D4 Pawn
believe it or not is a serious weakness
and it's a weakness
because the Knight on C3 is preventing
the C Pawn from inching upward and
protecting D4 as is very customary in
most London system lines that's part of
the appeal of Queen B6 in London system
typically white doesn't put the Knight
on C3 white of course puts the pawn on
C3 the defender of the D4 Pawn primarily
is this F3 Knight if we can take it off
the board then white will have
problems in the long run defending D4 if
white plays this very carefully and he
can get out of it but we're already
putting serious pressure on this Pawn
we can take the Knight but we don't
really have to I think a better idea is
just to develop our Knight and to
continue pressuring the D4 Pawn now you
might look at this and say well doesn't
white have the ability to move this
Knight now is it 95 something to be
concerned about 95 might very well be
the best move
in fact I think it might be the only way
for white to cleanly keep equality
but after 95 we take the bishop on E2
and if white takes back with a queen
then he drops the pawn on D4
so after 95 Bishop takes C2 white has to
recapture with the Knight
and at the very least in that position
we can just play E6 and develop our
Bishop and we have a super comfortable
position as some of you in the chat are
very accurately pointing out this
resembles an exchange Karo Khan and in
fact the London system has the capacity
to transpose into the exchange Karo Khan
because you get essentially the same
Pawn structure this is an exchange Karo
Pawn structure but Bishop E3 is a sign
that our opponent isn't happy with his
position he's going backward he's over
protecting the D4 plot and he's giving
us just an opportunity to develop our
pieces to Ideal squares again you can
take the Knight on F3 but I don't see
the need to give away the bishop pair
we're not really afraid of white playing
Knight E5 that move doesn't really carry
any kind of Venom so let's continue
developing our pieces we do this by
playing E6
G6 is not particularly good in this kind
of structure because we want to make
sure that our own Center Pawn is
reinforced and of course this bishop uh
if you're a car Recon player you should
know this belongs on D6 in these kinds
of structures
um perhaps some of you particularly
newer players might might be attracted
to the look of Bishop to B4 because it
looks like a more active move but Bishop
before actually justifies the placement
of White's Rook what you don't want to
do is give away your your dark squared
Bishop that easily because yeah you
damaged White's Pawn structure at least
visually but then the Rook on B1
actually occupies an open file our
Queen's going to be pushed away from B6
and why we'll be able to use the doubled
pawns as a battering ram and Advance the
the tip uh the top Pawn to C4 and
contest Etc I'll I'll show you uh that
kind of scenario after the game H3 okay
so our opponent forces us to decide
again we're adhering to the strategy of
not giving up the bishop pair without a
clear reason I still don't see a reason
to give up the bishop pair where do we
go well Bishop F5 is possible but I kind
of like the tension that we're exerting
on White's light squared Bishop so let's
drop it back to H5
and this is a boring position from a
tactical standpoint but as I've been
saying now for a couple of hundred
points if you want to cross 2000 and you
want to climb at this level you need to
know how to win boring positions right
you need to know how to win grinding
grindy maneuvering positional games
because you cannot at this point steer
every game particularly with black into
the direction that makes you happy right
you just you can't force it and you have
to embrace embrace the suck if you're a
tactical player who finds these kind
this kind of chest to be dry and insipid
and I'm That Kind of player but I've
kind of learned to enjoy the the process
of playing positions that don't always
make me feel comfortable
okay so our opponent is thinking black
is doing great here our pieces are all
nicely developed our next step is to
Castle queenside kingside and then of
course we will
move on to the next step which is to
develop a middle game plan
and our middle game plan is is not going
to be to put more pressure on the D4
Pawn because we can't do that our
opponent has protected it a thousand
ways and I don't see any way for us to
exert more pressure on Newport we're
gonna have to transition our play to
another side of the board okay A3 not
sure exactly what white wants I don't
think B4 is is dangerous in the least
because
well first of all doesn't really do
anything and second of all the night on
C3 is left without a Defender
but if we wanted to defend against B4 we
could and in fact there is a move that I
really really like because this is a
move that I was going to propose anyway
it's a move that I was going to play
after we had castled but in the context
of white playing A3 I think this move
makes even more sense because it
completely takes the sting out of B4
does anybody see what I'm talking about
and the fact that B4 leaves this night
undefended is a big hint so we need to
make a move such that after B4 we can
exploit the undefended Knight well that
basically means putting a piece on C8
but if we put the Rook on C8 white
actually can still play B4
because there you might spot the
discovered attack Knight takes before
but then White's Rook pins the Knights
of the queen and white can simply move
this Knight away even to A2 and our
Knight is going to be lost so we kill
two birds with one stone and we drop the
queen back to C7 this is a super
important concept that I'll write down
and then I'll talk about at length after
the game which doesn't have a name but
it's the notion that a piece can be good
on a particular Square for a long time
and it can be very hard to move that
piece away because you almost get
emotionally attached to its place you're
like the queen on V6 it's pressuring D4
but that pressure has done its job it's
allowed us to develop our pieces nicely
and now it's time for the queen to kind
of seek greener pastures it's not doing
quite as much on B6 it sort of
overstated its welcome on C7 it's
combining with the bishop it's
pressuring the C file it's stopping
before it's also protecting the E5
Square which renders the move 95 rather
unwise because it will drop a pawn so
I'm going to note this down he's doing
its job
okay
now of course we're gonna Castle there's
a third thing that Queen C7 does which
is that it paves the way for the path of
our own people right we can play B5 why
would we play B5 in such a position well
it's not really to play B4 right because
if you advance this Pawn to B4 what do
you achieve white simply plays a takes
before
and all that you've done is created a
weakness on A6 an isolated plot so what
is the purpose of playing a move like B5
well it's nothing overly profound you
just grab some space on the queen side
you clamp down on the C4 Square then you
start slowly squeezing white off the
board making it more difficult for white
to do what he wants to do queen D2
doesn't really achieve all that much our
opponent is connecting his Rooks we
shouldn't overthink this let's Castle
and this is the stage of the game where
our development is complete and where we
kind of start Crossing
um artes and dotting our eyes that's I
think the best way to describe it where
it's not that we have already a big plan
but we have some low hanging fruit we
have a couple of moves that we can play
almost without thinking that clearly
improve our position and set ourselves
up for ultimately something more
concrete what are those moves right
those are the kinds of moves newer
players struggle to play because they
don't always see exactly what they
achieve but the point is you don't have
to know exactly what it achieves you
just have to know that it won't damage
your position and as some of you are
pointing out Rook ac8 is exactly one of
those moves a rook on the C file you
never know when this could come in handy
and another one of those moves slightly
more ambitious is to play B5 I like the
move B5
I like the Mover kc8 if you want to be
maximally flexible then you should play
Rook C8 if you want to be more ambitious
then you should play B5 in a real game I
would probably go B5 so I'm going to do
it here as well I'm gonna go B5
grab space makes it harder for white to
breathe
another one of those moves is H6 by the
way just make some lift
your instinct to this might be well what
about Bishop takes H6 and that has to be
calculated on a case-by-case basis this
is a sack that a lot of players fear
unconditionally but it's actually not
always dangerous and this is a case of
Bishop takes H6 not being dangerous if
you just calculate so for instance H6
takes takes takes and then we have this
nice defensive move Bishop H5 to G6
in order to keep the Knight on F6 and
white is at a complete dead end white
has no pieces in the attack and there
are no mating squares so in that
position the move Knight G5 just doesn't
pose any threats because H7 is under
lock and key okay
and let's see what our opponent chooses
here
super comfortable position
why is it difficult for white to find a
move because it's not clear what to do
we have no Targets in the position if
white tries to move this Knight away
typical plan to move the Knight away and
go C3 then white gives up this very
important E4 square and we can put a
knight there with Tempo and then we can
follow up with F5 and then we could
start playing on the king side actually
is Bishop G5 annoying for black yeah I I
was waiting for someone to bring that up
Bishop to G5 is actually a decent move I
would consider it myself in in a real
game there's a a somewhat tactical
reason that Bishop G5 might fail which
is the response Knight to E4 we'll
calculate that if he plays it but the
funny thing is Bishop G5 doesn't even
really threaten Bishop takes F6 because
after GF we get the bishop pair and
Visually our King Side Pawn structure is
ugly but it's essentially unexploitable
which is another concept that you really
have to wrap your head around which is
that when you weaken your king side like
that you shouldn't rule out the move
just because it looks ugly and the queen
is coming to H6 and I'll show you some
lines after the game White's pieces are
so passive that even in the event of
Bishop G5 Bishop takes F6 why wouldn't
have the Machinery to really do anything
to bother us on the king side B4 that is
quite a move that is quite a move it's a
very weakening move and I think we can
exploit it automatically by playing Rook
C8 now which Rook you might ask well
there is a case to be made for both
Rooks actually
let me think about this for a second my
instinct is Rook ACA to keep the other
one on the king so you never know when
it could come in handy on the king side
on the other hand Rook FC it keeps the
stroke on the a file and there is a
non-zero possibility that the a file
opens up we could open it up later with
A5 not now because B5 would fall or
white could play A4 and a takes B5 and
then we would we would be thankful that
we kept this Rook on a closed file these
are hard decision it's not like GMS have
a secret key that allows me to make an
informed decision about where to put my
Rook the more I look at this though the
more I can appreciate Rook FCA because
the action is going on on the queen side
the king side is not where the fun is at
not where the party is at so
huh very hard decision actually I I
don't know I'll be honest I don't know
which move is better they're probably
about equivalent you don't want to waste
too much time on it we're already quite
short of time hmm
let's go Rook FC let's sort of follow
the positional rules
which dictate that okay action is
happening on the queen side so let's
assemble our pieces where the fun is
happening and black is already much
better of course the other drawback of
the move before is that it creates a
massive weakness on C4 where eventually
we would want to put a knight easier
said than done what is the fastest way
of getting a knight to C4 it's a worthy
question to ask there is a way to do it
in three moves we could play Knight F6
to D7 to B6
and then we would be ready to put it on
C4 but of course you don't want to put
it on C4 as long as there's a bishop on
E2 nimsovich talked about this and I'll
talk about this a little bit after the
game as well you want to occupy a weak
square with pieces when you occupy a
weak square with a pawn nimsovich
compared it to going to the dentist and
like getting a cavity filled so if you
imagine the Knight getting to C4 and
then white taking it and you taking it
with a pawn you're not extracting
no pun intended get away from the dental
theme you're not extracting the benefit
of occupying a weak Square because when
a pawn sits on it there's no Square you
can't use that square for your benefit
but hopefully your your appreciating the
general concept and I'll make it more
concrete after the game and maybe we'll
even get a chance to carry this out
during the game
if that pawn is a pass Pawn it's
different
of course and and there are exceptions
to every rule that I share there are
situations where yeah you you can take
back with a pawn maybe I'll even find
one after the game
yeah it's going to be a fun analysis
because I'll be able to talk about a lot
of important foundational positional
Concepts now
of course you might also notice that
after Knight D7 Knight B6 we have a tool
available at our disposal to deflect
this bishop we can trade our Bishop for
the Knight and either white has to
completely ruin his structure and given
the weakness is already in existence on
the queen side this makes White's
position even harder to spend or after
Bishop F3 it allows us to put the Knight
on C4 so let's think many many good
moves here give me 30 seconds here just
to try to try to squeeze the most out of
this position it's too early to think
about tactics but there's just so many
good candidate moves here and I don't
want to make
I don't want to do something that gives
white unnecessary counter play and it's
very easy to do that by the way when you
have a lot of good options I don't love
Knight D7 actually
the reason I don't love it is because I
like the placement of this Knight I like
the way this Knight is placed because
it's it's ready to jump into E4 the
moment this Knight moves so that's
and that's not to my liking we could
play Bishop takes F3 already and just
get rid of this Knight also don't love
giving away the bishop pair hmm
Bishop F3 is not bad at all
the more I look at it
you know what move I really really like
here Knight to B8 I really like the look
of this move 90 B8 maybe a mistake I I
you know these positions are are very
hard to play accurately but hopefully
it's halfway decent
what are we doing well
we are getting the site around to B6 you
might say well didn't I just say that
this could be done in three moves why am
I doing it in four well there's two
things to keep in mind the center is
closed which means that the value of
each individual Tempo is greatly
diminished we can afford to do something
informal so we could have done it in
three and as I just mentioned I like the
placement of the other night and the
final thing is that it also opens up the
C file which increases the pressure on
the Knight which makes it even harder
for whites to move now Bishop D3 is an
impatient move by our opponent Bishop
takes F3 is begging to be played we
should keep in mind that this gives
white a sliver of counter play on the
king side white will probably play Rook
q1 I think this is what our opponent is
banging on but
even if white plays that we can always
put our Jeep on on G6 and because
White's Pawn structure is so bad white
is unable to use his pawns to shatter
our King's our Pawn Skeleton on the king
side and I just don't feel like white is
enough pieces to smash through with a
set with sacrifices and I'm doing this
without calculation
I think we can afford to continue our
plan with my bd7
but we need to find the right time to
play G6
a move that I think if you're newer to
chess and you're watching this you're
like G6 man I I but I was taught never
to make a move like this unless you
absolutely have to and what you're
watching is an exception to the rule in
fact the pawn on G6 is much safer than
it is on G7 because on G7 it can be
targeted with moves like Bishop to H6
um I'll delve into this more after the
game okay Rook to G1 so right now there
are still no threats and you could say
well why don't we wait for white to play
Bishop H6 and only then play G6 to
conserve time and that's a reasonable
point but I don't see the need to
procrastinate with this I think if we
already play G6 we don't have to worry
about you know maybe even a sack on G7
or something you never know what kind of
stuff can can hurt you in time pressure
so
you know my my cautious side of the
brain says to play G6 King h8 also a
very good defensive move lots of options
here that allow us to make sure our King
is completely safe
um
King age let's go G6 let's let's uh
check this one off our list
I'm anticipating H4 I think most people
would go H4 here but H4 is an empty move
it doesn't create a threat and it
doesn't create a threat because H5 is
controlled by D2 okay also reasonable
now I think we need to be very concrete
we can play Knight B6 Knight C4 as we
intended earlier but I think there's a
nice defensive move here that we could
throw in to make it difficult for white
to develop his kingside counter play and
that move
is Knight to H5 Knight to H5 Knights on
the rim are amazing as the expression
goes
and H5 what is would what is what are we
doing and didn't I say that I like the
placement of the Knight on F6 well
things changed when we took on F3
because when we took on F3 one of the
small drawbacks of that move was that
this F Pawn is now restricting our
Knight so our Knight again same concept
when we played Queen to C7 it was good
at one time but the structure changed
and now it's time for the night to
fulfill another role and the role that
it's full selling right now is
preventing whitesnite from jumping into
the attack notice how the Knight on H5
even though it's on the rim I have a
great example of that is restricting its
counterpart which is in the center which
happens sometimes and it happens because
our other pieces are superior because
we're controlling the G3 square with
three pieces white only with two the
pawn on The Rook at G3 is impossible
same reason Knight F4 is impossible
white is essentially Frozen in place on
the king side but there is a deeper
reason why I like that H5 and this is
really Advanced not saying this to to my
own heart just to give you some context
but
our opponent took this in another
Direction F4 clearly he's intending the
move F5 we need to be tactically alert
F5 is not a move that we want to allow
because you can't take back with a
g-pawn EF there's Bishop takes F5 last
thing we want is to give black white
counter play let me think for a second
I have a really cool move
oh man I think I see a really really
nice idea
but let me just confirm that it worked
because at this point we're starting to
rely a little bit on our calculation and
tactics here's the move we are going to
play
hmm
so the simple way is to play King AJ but
I don't want to be simple I want to be
sophisticated and sophisticated
sometimes means mistake but hopefully
not this time Queen d8 and this actually
was the third thing that I wanted to
point out before our opponent played F4
which is that when we played Knight H5
it actually opened up a pathway for our
Queen to join the king side attack
remember whites the one with the ruined
kingside Pawn structure which means
theoretically we are the ones who should
be attacking on the king's side and
that's what I'm starting to do and I was
gonna say that it indirectly prevents
the move Knight's G3 there is I think a
beautiful idea here
there is a business-like move you can do
this in a very straightforward fashion
or you can do this in beautiful fashion
does anybody see the Tactical solution
here so the straightforward move is
Queen to H4 because it threatens
Checkmate but I think there is a much
more beautiful move which is Knight
takes F4 Bishop takes up and then Queen
H4 with a double attack
it threatens Checkmate it threatens the
bishop on F4
it threatens Jackman to threatens the
bishop on F4 let me just double check
this
all right
let me double check this
steak Stakes Queen H4
hmm
I don't see a defense I don't see a
defense I think it works
because if it doesn't work we lose the
game that's the thing that's the danger
of these types of tactics
and it's inevitable that you have to
rely on this kind of stuff you cannot
avoid it even if you play the greatest
positional game and you maneuver like
karpov and a Kappa Blanca and your
opponent is biting the dust at some
point you're gonna have a moment where
you have to convert your advantage and
that means calculation tactics Etc I by
the way I think Queen H4 is a much is a
better move there is a crazy resource
that white has I saw but I can't resist
it's too beautiful of a move it's too
beautiful of a move but it does allow
one little defensive resource which I
think gives white a glimmer of hope
which the move Queen H4
does not allow and you guys can figure
this out on your own we'll see if our
opponent finds it
and I'm regretting it slightly because
this violates like rule number one of
the speedrun which is that I play the
moves that I would play in a real game
and in a real game I would go Queen H4
but hopefully I can be forgiven for that
what was I going to say yeah so that's
why
I always say that if there's only one
thing that you study in chess it's
tactics
because everything ultimately boils down
to tactics as it does here Bishop F4
Queen H4 Bishop takes D6 Queen takes H3
is checkmate and white simply has no way
to defend both our opponent doesn't find
the move the move by the way was Knight
to F5 I'll unpack this after the game
forget about it for now here the
follow-up is obvious now we bring our
Queen into the attack with Queen to H4
of course
we should never give up this night we
have to force our opponent to take it
now we get the dark squares now we get
the dark squares and we get the bishop
in the attack and now our our attention
shifts entirely to the king side we're
up a pawn but we're not resting on our
Laurels now White's King is in trouble
we need to find a way before White's
coordinated the rest of his pieces to
throw our pieces from the queen side to
the king side how do we do that
well you might look at this well okay
the move clearly is Knight to F6 but
again what does Knight F6 achieve what
exactly it is achieve nothing because it
doesn't threaten Knight G4 white will be
able to take the queen
so there is a move that I like a lot
more which still involves the Knight but
it does it indirectly now what's one of
the main rules of attacking well when
you're attacking oftentimes you want to
open up the center you want to open up
more physical space on the board which
allows you to attack more efficiently so
the move E5 actually comes to mind
I really like the look of E5 if you
wanted to approach this more
positionally you could drop this bishop
back to let's say D6 and open up a line
of fire on the DC on the D4 plot but
that's not Meredith ski style chess we
gotta capitalize on our chances and play
E5
all right
and de we play Knight 65 automatically
and why does the Knight on E5
do something and the Knight on F6
doesn't it it has to do with the open
e-file first of all the 995 is better
placed because it's in the center but
second of all our next move very likely
is going to be Rook C8 to E8 and for the
third time in the game first time was
when we played Queen C7 the second time
was when we played Knight to H5 and now
the third time where a piece is
perfectly placed on a certain Square the
circumstances change and so does the
role that this piece plays in the larger
scheme of phase Rook was on C8 to
pressure C2 that was a long gone era now
it's time for this Rook to participate
in the attack
how can it most efficiently participate
in the attack well we could put it on
the open file but that's not the only
thing that The Rook could do we could
also lift it around to app six why would
you do that well I'm noticing that
there's a big weakness on F2 and Rook is
the perfect piece to use for that
another benefit of this move is that the
other Rook could join in the attack as
well I really like the look of Rook to
C6
we also could have there's like a
million things you can do here
um and if you're watching this and say
well why not this move why not this move
chances are those moves are also
possible I'm just choosing one of
several possible paths the roof C6 recap
six
and of course then we could move the
bishop and open up a direct attack on
the F2 Pawn then when necessary the
other Rook could join in Via let's say
e8s
white is running out of moves he's down
upon his position is ruined no
coordination is completely lost but we
need that crushing blow let's see if we
can do it in style okay I might have to
talk a little bit less here
during the last part of the game because
I'm I'm trying to find some tactics to
end the game in style
okay so Bishop F1 the first thing I see
when this move is played is that the C2
Pawn has been released right and I'm
almost emotionally attached to the
concept of winning the game on the queen
side because that's where we started
everything in the first place so what
move comes to mind on the topic of total
flexibility oh there's a tactic which
almost works and it's beautiful but it
doesn't quite work yeah no
it started oh it's not even close
because the square is dependent
Rook C8 Queen 65 okay C8 let's go Rook
C8 of course did we blunder D5 no I just
don't care about this Pawn
if we can take C2 the floodgates
officially open and we crash through
okay let me think here I gotta do a
little bit of calculation make sure we
don't you know ruin something in the end
because that happens unfortunately too
often with me leave it in the speed run
I've done it several times where I lose
my discipline and time pressure
I have a really nice move though planned
after Queen takes D5 it's a super classy
move it's a move that runs white out of
the center
white is no moves this is almost
resignable we need one or two more
accurate moves and the game is over
yeah gazing giraffe you deserve a sub
you're absolutely right the move that I
have in mind is Queen takes D5 and then
Rook C8 to d8 and that move is based
primarily on some tactics which are
quite easy to see because there if the
queen drops back to E4 it runs into the
X-ray Bishop takes G3 check wins the
queen
simply after Queen D5 Rook d8 the queen
has no good squares it has to go back
all the way to G2 out of the center and
then we could calmly pick up the pawn on
C2 or we could do something a little bit
more tactically minded but Rogue d8 I
think is the most accurate move you
could even play Rook D6 here if you want
it to be ultra fancy you could play Rook
D6 but there is no need to be fancy just
for the sake of being fancy
even though I'm a huge hypocrite because
that's literally just what I did but
here we're gonna play it simply just
because we're in time pressure
Queen G2 is Forest now you could play
Knight G4 but I think we'll save that
move for a rainy day 94king H1 and I'm
not entirely
sold on what this move achieves
although
holy smokes there's a beautiful line oh
but it's wait one sec
it's beautiful but there's no need
let's just take C2
okay I'm trying to win in beautiful
style but this is a dangerous Pursuit
it's a very dangerous Pursuit but we're
gonna follow this Pursuit and play
Knight G4
of course Rogue D2 ended the game
immediately
I just want to play beautifully
if possible
that would be the cherry on top okay now
let me think
the simplest is really DQ
okay I'll leave the beautiful line prep
for the game guys
just because
it would be wrong it would be wrong
of me wait actually whatever it would be
wrong of me but I'm gonna do it okay
I'm gonna do it anyway I don't care
because it's it's too beautiful to pass
this up it's too beautiful to pass this
up and it's completely winning this this
line is totally winning it's just a
little bit less winning than doing it
straightforwardly so the point is white
has to recapture with the queen
and then there is an incredible tactical
move does anybody see it
yes
and I'm gonna play it it's Rook takes F2
and if he takes the queen it's a mate in
the corner so he has to take my rook and
then he's two pawns down and is
completely lost
and if he goes here that's the very
important detail oh D2 almost wins but
that would be too fancy we simply take
the queen removing the defender of this
Rook maybe I exaggerated I didn't mean
to do that I was just excited to end the
game tactically and now it's over
couldn't resist I apologize
and he resigns good game
yeah
Rook takes F2
of course Knight takes that oh Knight F2
was winning on the spot
sorry I lost my mind Knight F2 was
winning on the spot here broke off two
queen G3 broke two three broke up two
this was actually the best one
so Knight G4 is the top move
and Bishop G3 is the top move it's just
at the very end that Knight F2 is is
superior all right let's analyze we've
got a lot to talk about in this game
Lots on pack
let me pull up chest space so that we
can do a little bit of analysis
okay
so we Face a London system and a load up
stockfish I have a little bit of
analysis here in a file let me pull that
up as well
and of course uh C5 so if you're
watching this and you already have a
line against the London that makes you
comfortable whether it's D5 or E6 or G6
you should continue playing it right and
the point here isn't just a forcibly
alter your repertoire I'm giving you
proposals but if you're already plus
something that makes you happy
you should continue playing
okay
so what are the options here for white
essentially white has a couple of
options there is dtake C5 but it's not
good and very rare
there is of course the move D5 which I
actually think might be why it's one of
White's better options but here I
actually have a nice line to show you
then there is the move that our opponent
played and finally there is the move C3
and one of the appeals of the move C5 is
that C3 is actually not that good
because here after Queen to B6 I think
white is like borderline worse
here why does borderline worse
why is borderline worse because it's
very hard to find a move
very hard to find a move you're
attacking V2
if white defends it with the queen like
this then
D4 Falls
except it doesn't fall you can't take D4
because you get checkmated on see it a
lot of games have ended like this on
leeches
but instead of course you bring your
knight out to C6
white has to play E3 and now you simply
play well either D6 or D5 both moves are
good I like D6 I like D6 and white
actually can lose this really quickly
after Knight C3 there is a really sexy
tactical move let's see if anybody
watching can find it if you're watching
on YouTube pause this is a standard and
super important theme in the London when
you have a queen on B6 so make sure that
you understand it
yeah it's it's this move Bishop to F5
and typically there is a knight on B1 so
the idea is that it traps the here it's
a slightly different
um scenario because you're forking the
Queen the rook and the Knight and white
is busted white has to lose one of these
pieces with check
uh so white is already in pretty bad
shape if he moves the queen you could
strike at the center with E5 you've got
a huge initiative white has to find this
move which looks like it loses tonight
to B4 but white can save himself with a
check you drop your Bishop back
now this is hanging and this is hanging
but why does Bishop B5 and here you have
another sexy tactical move can anybody
find this second very important idea and
this gives black a stable advantage
not Knight C2 although you're on the
right track Knight C2 is just a trade I
take and you take no big deal it's
Knight to D3 exactly you're using the
pin making the Knight Untouchable
forcing the king out why does the play
King E2 otherwise he loses the F2 Pawn
black plays Knight F4 ef4 and to hear
the move that I analyzed a while ago
it's still the best move according to
stockfish is to to position this bishop
on a superior Square
and if y takes it then you play uh you
can play BC you can play Queen C6 and
this end game is just better for black
better Pawn structure you've got a nice
Bishop you've got the B file
You're Gonna Go King D7 E6 and enjoy
your life you also have a monster Square
on D5 for your knight okay
um so that's essentially why C3 is bad
there are there's a better move in this
position which which very few people
know which which is Knight to D2 uh and
I analyzed Queen takes B2 and it leads
to like insane complications I think
it's much simpler to just go D5 here and
get essentially a superior version of a
standard London position if white plays
Queen to B3 here then you take on D4
forcing White's hand white has to take
the queen otherwise he loses the d-pawn
and typically as I've already explained
before the side that possesses the a
file has the edge even though your pawns
are visually a little bit ugly black is
much more comfortable Knight C63 Knight
B4 and White's got a lot of problems to
solve
so that's what happens after C3
D5 is definitely a more ambitious and
better move here my proposal is to play
the move D6
and there's a rare move that I found
which I think solves a lot of Black's
problems after Knight C3 and that's the
move E7 E5 you're kind of getting this
this weird Pawn triangle but you're
forcing white to commit if white takes
on passant then after Bishop takes C6
black is super comfortable
so typically white go Z4 you develop
your knight
white develops there Knight
you develop your bishop and
you might look at this and say well
isn't black worse because of the
backward Pawn the backward Pawn is a
temporary weakness right because you are
inevitably going to push D5 because
white cannot control this Square enough
times you're going to push D5 and after
that the structure is going to be
symmetrical and if anything I would
prefer black so for instance Bishop B2
castles castles you know what I mean you
just hurry to play D5 you can play H6
just to stop Knight G5 and on the next
move you can calmly play D5 and you're
doing fantastic
so that's on the side
if white doesn't on poisson and plays
Bishop to G5 there is a very nice
tactical detail here you go Bishop to E7
and whites actually not in trouble but
it's a difficult move it's a difficult
situation for white to deal with because
the natural move to me is E4 but this
runs into another tactic Knight takes D5
which is one that I've highlighted many
times on this stream the idea is that
the Knight simultaneously protects the
bishop so if white takes it you're able
to escape D5 if white takes the D5
Knight then uh you recapture the bishop
with an extra Pawn the line goes on the
light can give a check on B5
and you simply move the king over to f8
where it is completely safe and the
reason it's safe is because if white
plays Bishop C4 you can just defend with
Quincy Esau you can just depend with
quantism then you develop the Knight
you've got the D4 Square the queen on D5
is completely unstable you'll Chase it
away in a million different ways
typically white plays Knight F3 you drop
back to E7 in order to reinforce the D6
pawn and according to my analysis yes
white has enough compensation for the
pawn here but not more than that
by the way after Bishop C4 do not go
Bishop E6 because that blunders B7 and
The Rook is trapped instead you want to
go Queen to E8 and if white makes I
think the most natural move in the
position which is Castle's Queen side it
looks scary but white has no targets and
here you can play A6 in order to prepare
B5
and if white tries to do something
similar like H4 they just go H6 and
cover the G5 Square white is running out
of useful moves and the moment white
drops the queen away it's time for you
to start expanding on the queen side of
B5 this is unconventional chess I agree
this is sort of somewhat anti-positional
slightly computer-ish play but hopefully
you can see that white just doesn't have
a clear-cut plan here so after Bishop to
E7 white you know in many top level
games actually gives up the bishop pair
and here I think there's no question
that black is doing well with like
uncontested dark Square control E4 you
can almost transition this into a king's
Indian with G6 and then Bishop G7 and
eventually you can prepare the move F5
this is at least what I analyzed and yes
like you're watching on YouTube this is
technical
but again you have to ask yourself like
yes it's a little bit dry and stuff but
you have to know this stuff because the
London is super popular if you know this
stuff it's giving you it will give you a
huge push so the analysis that I just
conducted here with E4 Knight takes D5
there are some Alternatives of course
white for example can play Knight takes
D5 and I didn't talk about this because
this doesn't this is just a bad move
because black plays Bishop takes you
back and here black actually is able to
Castle and if black is able to Castle
then where is White's compensation
obviously this check is not dangerous
you can just go into 8c6
so in any case that is Bishop G5 if
white plays Bishop to G3
if white plays Bishop to G3 then the
bishop is terrible on G3 it's just
biting on granite and here there are
some really really cool ideas the engine
actually proposes H5 which I love it's a
very challenging move you're grabbing
space on the king side
typically white will respond to the H3
and now watch this this is amazing chess
this is like high energy stockfish chess
but this is the kind of engine chest
that I really really like to see you go
H4
and now you go B5 you exploit the fact
that the bishop is still undeveloped now
who can tell me what the idea is after
Knight takes B5 and it's not like there
is a specific tactical idea you give
this check
but here you make a quiet move and this
is what I love you basically play this
benko Gambit style the point is to
prevent White
from playing E4 I think most people most
of you are probably thinking let's go
94. but you don't even have to go 94 you
just develop your other pieces you go
Knight bd7 and white is just in terrible
shape this bishop this bishop
everything's terrible and if white goes
let's say Knight F3 black is almost
winning after Rook B
White's position is collapsing at the
Seas Rogue B1 bang there's this tactic
and here's a beautiful tactic for you if
white plays Rook takes then you
obviously take the Knight and take the
Rook what about Queen D2 who can find
the most accurate path to Victory it's a
gorgeous move
pause if you're watching on YouTube
especially if you're a newer player this
is something that you can definitely
find
this is something you can definitely
find Queen takes Knight exactly
deflection
take the Rook
the queen and you'll be upper Rook at
the end of the line
so just one of you know many many
just to give you a flavor of how
dangerous this can be so the move B5
here puts white Under very very serious
pressure and H5 merely grabs space on
the king side if white tries to defend
it with this piece again you can make
one move like this and White's Knight is
immobilized it white moves the Knight
immediately you trap the bishop with H4
Knight E4 instead of Queen takes E3 is
also winning yeah 94 immediately is also
winning but less beautiful
and that basically is it for D5 you go
D6 you go E5 are there Alternatives
absolutely I won't analyze this for an
hour
white can go also C4 But Here Also I
think E5 is quite strong your your
strategies don't change here like you
basically do the exact same thing
um as you would after after Knight C3 so
that's a bit of a road map uh to
conducting that position question by
Lion King why'd you go Bishop H4 or H4
after H5
so real quick could white go Bishop H4
Bishop H4 is maybe even better than H3 I
just think it's less
you know it's less likely to happen in
the game
um let me just check what what the
engine gives here
the engine
after Bishop H4 gives Queen B6 actually
interesting or sorry Bishop page four
which is the top engine move by the way
it gives Queen B6
Queen B6 Rook B1 has to defend upon ibd7
now oh my God this is just three look at
this if white goes E4 black has Knight
takes E4 these tactics I've never
actually seen before in the London 94
and queen before and because there are
two pieces on the fourth rank you're
gonna take one of them either the Knight
or the bishop white loses
and it's not easy for white to find a
move here after an ibd7 if white plays
Knight F3
then you go E4 y drops the Knight back
you go E3 and you roll in White's entire
King side and then you just develop your
pieces with Bishop p7 you've got a great
position
so that's the short answer okay let's
move on to the next slide and the next
line of course is E3
for one minute I'll tell you what to do
if white plays DC if white plays DC the
best move in my opinion is Knight to A6
and there is some Theory here there is
some Theory here but this line is very
very hard to play for white it's not
good at all the main move according to
the database is Queen D4 I know you
simply play Queen A5 check and pick up
the pawn so for instance let's say I
play C3 do not play Knight takes C5 and
walk into B4 play Queen takes C5 here
typically white plays E3 and the engine
likes dropping the queen back to C6 you
keep the Queens on the board if white
takes black has a fantastic end game
you've got a better Center etc etc and
after Queen C6 Knight F3 uh you play the
move D6
and now E5 is already a massive threat
it's not easy to defend against white is
worse
if white covers in this case with a
Knight Knight C3 then of course you can
play Knight takes C5 and the difference
is that after before you have this move
with the pawn on C3 the pawn was
defending McQueen so this would lose a
piece but with the Knight you can play
Knight C5 before 96. you might say ah
Bud Light has a Desperado sack on F6 no
he does not you can just play Queen's
xb4 and white is collapsing everything
is hanging okay
so this is not a dangerous move at all
nothing to be afraid of and finally we
get to the move that our opponent played
which is E3 and this is the topical we
respond with cded and queen to B6
by the way the The Uncommon move is C
takes D4 most people play the immediate
Queen B6 that's the most popular line
but I like to take first because it well
first of all it prevents the move Queen
C1 because this Pawn is hanging but also
it leads to a relatively fresh position
okay so what can I say about this
position
well first of all black scores extremely
well in the database well over 50
percent the most common move is the one
that our opponent played but what's good
is that it's not really the engine
recommendation and the engine does give
equality here according to the engine
White's best chance at a small Edge is
to play Knight A3 which is extremely
uncommon you think Eric Rosen might give
this in one of his videos but this is
not a move that you play if you come off
the street like it's hard to just come
up with Knight A3 what is the difference
between Knight A3 and Knight C3 well
this leaves the C Pawn free to move up
to C3 and that's the chief difference
you have to keep this D4 upon well
protected if you're playing white and
you want to play this in the spirit of
the London so here there is a very
interesting move which is Knight F6 to
D5
forcing the bishop all the way back to
C1
all the way back to C1
um an amazing line is Knight to C4 which
a lot of people play even a 2500 played
a smooth what does Knight C4 run into
who can tell me pause the video if
you're watching these are all ideas that
you will get a chance to carry out and
maybe I'll do a separate London video
it's actually occurring to me to do a
London for black video Queen to E6 check
exactly and you're attacking the bishop
you're attacking the king
white has to drop back to E3 and now
bang you play on The Queen side forcing
the Knight away
the Knight has to move to E5 otherwise
white drops a Pawn on E3 and now you
develop to C6
this is a game played in 2016 between
two Argentinian players and black is uh
black is dominating here Knight gf3 you
go F6
you attack the Knight Knight C6 93
Intermezzo fv3 Queen E3 you win a pawn
you have the bishop pair you're in great
shape
so Knight C4 is a blunder white has to
go Bishop C1 and now the best idea is to
play the move E6
you develop and open up a diagonal for
the bishop here white goes Knight to C4
you drop the queen back to C7 and I
think the black is doing perfectly fine
here I have not been able to find an
edge for white in this entire line
according to the engine typically white
plays Knight F3 you play B6 and develop
your Bishop uh the game Tang against
oparan and Eric Rosen has two games in
this position 2018 and 20 and 21. he
lost the game in 2018 sorry he won in
2018 lost in 2021 Eric in 2021 played
Knight C4 to E3 against akshat Chandra
and he got absolutely nothing and if
Eric Gets nothing that means it's equal
because here you can simply Play Bishop
to B7 and Eric played Knight 65 Bishop
takes D5
Bishop D3
but black is a great position here black
is a great decision here you can play
Bishop B4 check and believe it or not
the king is forced to move to F1 because
if white plays C3 then well because
Bishop takes C3 check this is what I
love about this line it's so full of
these types of tactics because your
pieces are super active and if you block
with the bishop then you give up D3
so Eric was forced to move his King to
F1 akshot played uh Castle's kingside
and black has a fantastic position here
I would prefer black here in 2018 Eric
played the move C3 uh in in this
position and C3
I think is even a better move than than
Knight E3 but your strategy doesn't
change you play Bishop to B7 which was
not played in the game and if white
plays Bishop to E2 you have many many
different good setups the engine likes
the fiancado the other Bishop I
personally just prefer to play Bishop E7
castles and mid castle and Knight F4 is
an idea and why is black worse here
black has a completely healthy structure
you can play Knight C6 you can push a B5
and I really think that if you're if you
like active positions this is this is
the way to go
that's that's all there is to it as long
as you remember Knight to D5 and and E60
you're going to be in great shape
against the London
last theoretical remark and then we will
actually focus on the game itself
I might have to divide this into two
parts because there's so much to talk
about here
what happens if white plays B3 well
nothing happens if white plays B3 you
simply play D5 here and and white has
permanently weakened all of these Queen
side squares this is like an inferior
version of the game the one big thing to
remember is that Knight F3 is always met
with Bishop G4 if you miss the
opportunity to do that and you play
Knight to C6 you run the risk of
allowing a move like 95. in this
specific instance no 95 is impossible
but typically Your Instinct should be to
go Bishop to G4 in response to Knight F3
so this is nothing to worry about
okay Knight to C3 hopefully I'm not
boring into death completely and now we
play the move which I really really like
which is A6 Main Line black scores 59
here in classical OTB games according to
the database that's a staggering score
for the London that's a staggering score
for the London and Rogue B1 is not the
best move after this move I think
black's position is preferable I think
black is slightly better
the correct move here
um and the best way to maintain equality
for white is to play this typical London
idea A3 which is one that you're
probably familiar with if you've done
puzzle Rush this is the idea and the
queen is trapped
uh so here you obviously adhere to the
general strategy playing D5 the main
move is Knight F3
you can play Bishop G4
and black is a great position uh Andrew
Tang against Jeffrey Zhang 2021 speed
Chess Championship
continued Knight to A4 was Andrew's move
um Andrew's the only one to play this
move that's a decent move but it doesn't
do anything you play Queen A5 check and
after C3 what did Andrew Overlook
actually sorry it's not a decent mode I
thought what I meant to say that's not
what I meant to say it's a bad vote why
why
because you take an F3 the queen is
overloaded can't take with the queen you
have to take with a pawn and just look
at this yes and now black plays E6 black
is slightly better
so again Andrew is struggling which
means this is a good line eight games in
the database against Bishop P2 and black
has won all eight games all of them have
been won by black including a 2197 who
beat a 2500.
played this with black 2650 and the
reason is because it's just a bad I mean
London players hate playing with a
knight on C3 because they hate having a
weakness on T4 that's not what they
signed up for they signed up for the
exact opposite black just play C6
white typically castles here and here
the most thematic approach is to play
Bishop F3 Bishop F3 Knight C6 and to put
pressure on the pawn the engine also
likes the move Knight b2d7
which I think is an entirely reasonable
alternative you're covering the E5
Square
and uh two games continue to Rook B1 and
now you play Bishop D6 and you have
essentially like an excellent version of
an exchange Caro oh I keep mentioning
The Exchange car you bet like why are
you mentioning The Exchange car what am
I talking about well in the exchange
Carl you get a very similar structure
after D5 edcd this is a type of position
which can literally come out of a London
this structure and the most common way
that it comes out of a London is if
let's say here black plays C5 white
plays E3 this is the same structure and
it can even be the same position right
it could be literally the same position
if y plays Bishop F4 you have yourself a
London eventually
okay
so in the exchange Caro a lot of
beginners play the move Knight to C3
here Knight to C3 is well known to be a
serious positional mistake precisely for
the reason that the D4 Pawn now becomes
a serious weakness and black starts to
attack it does that make sense that is
why white is advised to play C3 that's
the whole backbone of the London okay so
back we go to the game that's what you
do if white plays A3 after Rook B1 the
strategy doesn't change we play the move
D5
let me see if there's still games in the
database there are actually a lot of
games sadwani against opard now roundock
played H3 here which in the context of
of the game you know why he played H3
but this is not dangerous either here
black can developed the bishop to F5
that's what grishopard did sadwani
played Knight F3 or paren played E6
he played Bishop D3 yeah you've avoided
Bishop G4 big deal big deal you're still
you still have a great position this was
a bliss tournament by the way but still
a par and played great and just Bishop
takes D3 Queen takes D3 you can play
Bishop to E7
castles Knight C6 I mean zero problems
in Black's position the position is
equal
now if you were playing white here what
do you think white should do to make
sure that the position is equal what is
the best way to make lemonade out of
lemons if you're playing white who can
tell me and this is a good idea if
you're a London player first of all get
out of my stream but second of all you
should know this idea if for some reason
in the unlikely event you have a knight
on C3 it is often advisable to move the
Knight back yeah 92. and then to follow
up with above C3 as unpleasant as it is
to give up the FourSquare and yes we
would play 94 here still it's important
to keep the spawn protected black is
doing great nonetheless
so white plays Knight F3 we play Bishop
to G4 there are still games in the
database actually quite a few of them
and even some Grand Master games
first time this occurred was in 1995. uh
Bishop B2 all 11 games featured this
move
Knight to C6 uh four games in the
database with this move our opponent's
next move is not a novelty three games
in the database
uh with with this move so we're still
following a couple of classical games E6
and already black is slightly better of
course castles
Bishop to D6 man when did we deviate
from these games
um our opponent played H3 one game
continued H3 in 2019
Bishop H5
and the point of deviation was here A3
is technically a novelty it's not the
greatest novelty in the world but it is
but if wength is watching this stream
and he's wondering like where exactly
did white become worse I think the
moment where the position goes from
equal to worse is here I think after
Bishop E3 Black's position is just
fantastic this is the last chance to
claim equality and I think the way to do
that would have been to play Knight to
E5 and the idea is that after Bishop
takes E2 which is forced you can't take
the spawn the bishop is hanging white
takes back with the Knight white takes
back with the Knight and this is an
extremely common idea to take back with
the knight in order to be able to play
C3 and the position is completely equal
it's likely to end in a draw E6 C3 and
blah blah blah you know uh for example I
don't know 95 Bishop E5 Bishop B7 and
both sides are are extremely solid here
but you're super happy with black
um in any case
this was I think the last chance to to
cleanly equalize because already here
you can play 95 but it doesn't come with
quite the same effect and I think white
should have still played 95 and the
situation kept getting worse the more
development moves would be played
because eventually 95 stops being
possible
so E6 castles Bishop D6 H3 Bishop h5a3
kind of another waste of a move I think
Wang didn't know what to do and here I
really really like Queen to C7 the
concept of
um the concept of a piece having already
done its job on a square it Queen did
tremendous things on B6 but now it's
time to move it to a square where it's
more well coordinated with the rest of
the pieces essentially and of course the
Tactical idea is that B4 is now
temporarily prevented uh due to Knight
takes before
simple tactics discovered attack you win
you take the Knight back you're up at
full point oh hey archers
okay so white played Queen D2 which is a
completely understandable move
uh defending the Knight and there's
still a game in the database by
transposition but here already white is
in very serious trouble the computer
evaluation here just so you know is
minus over plus it's around -1
so it's not just like white is
uncomfortable White's position sucks
here because white has no plan his
position is full of weaknesses super
passive and black has very clear-cut
ways to improve his position which is
exactly what we did and our opponent
just doesn't know what to do king H1 we
continue to improve with B5
and B4 I think is honestly what takes
this position from much worse to very
close to lost I wouldn't call White's
position lost just yet but I would call
it borderline lost and this is panic
right B4 is the product of our opponent
just not knowing what to do what could I
propose here with white
not much I think White's position is
awful
perhaps the most practical move is to
try to get some pieces off the board to
try to get these Bishops off the board
when you're extremely cramped
the kind of textbook method of trying to
generate a little bit more breathing
room is to trade pieces so the move that
I would actually make is Knight to G1
which I know is sad yeah it's very sad
but at least you're trying to get some
stuff off the board here at least you're
coordinating your Knights
and then you could proceed perhaps to
try to get the Bishops off the other
Bishops off the board with Bishop to F4
so that's what I would do there was a
question during the game is Bishop to G5
uh a dangerous move and the answer of
course is is no and to illustrate that
first of all there is the move Knight E4
here but let's say that black plays King
h8
if whiteway's Bishop F6 and queen H6 you
just dropped the bishop back to G6 there
is literally not a single idea for white
on the king's side because this is
visually ugly but it's incredibly solid
and moreover black can use this to his
Advantage by Shifting The Rook over to
G8 and using the G file a little bit
later in the game in order to generate
an attack so if you're a newer player
but the takeaway from this is that you
shouldn't automatically take F6 or take
F3 you should assess the specifics of
the situation here I wouldn't give up
the dark Squad Bishop if I was playing
White
okay
so our opponent plays B4 exacerbating
the situation even further immediately
we exploit the um undefended Knight with
Rook f2ca good move by our opponent Rook
B3 and I'm really really proud of the
move Knight I think Knight V8 from a
positional standpoint is an excellent
move
um and it's an instructive move and it's
it's an idea that most of you guys
should be familiar with but I all I am
very partial in general to uh retreating
Night Moves I love retreating night
moves and I love them particularly when
they're part of a larger maneuver
just a moment of course there is a very
very famous uh retreating night maneuver
I I would even go so far as to call it
the most famous retreating night
maneuver in the history of Chess this is
a game that is shown to all Russian
School boys it's like the Ultimate
Classic Russian Schoolboy game and the
Russian Schoolboy move
and you will be among the
lucky
ones to acquaint yourself with this game
perhaps some of you have even seen this
move
I really this move made a huge
impression on me when this game was
first shown to me as as a kid it is
white to play in this position between
uh as you can see Aaron nimsovich and
Akiba Rubenstein to Old Masters
top players in the world and in this
position white makes a move that made a
huge impression on me does anybody know
the move that Mr
nimsovich played in this position
anybody knew he plays a retreating night
move well there's exactly one of them
and that's the move Knight to H1 and as
you can see by the arrows he's going to
G5 and he's going to G5 in order to
deliver Checkmate to the white king
most students who I've given this to
they start by proposing this move
because it feels you get a rush from
putting that on issue but it doesn't do
anything black just plays G6 and forces
the Knight back whereas the Knight on G5
is going to be a lot harder to kick away
because it can always jump into E6 or if
the circumstances are right into F7 so
the way that the game continued and this
is important right when you're
conducting a maneuver a lot of people
think okay I want to go this this and
this and then you close your eyes and
you make these four moves come hell or
high water you freaking go Knight H3 no
matter how many pieces you give up
that's not how real chess Works in in
reality sometimes you make two
maneuvering moves then you react to your
opponent's move which is exactly what
names does here and then later on you
continue the maneuver right here is
exactly what image he plays Rook if you
want he says no no no I'm not giving
away the e-file I can play Knight H3
whenever I want to but I need that
e-file for myself
and now he continues the maneuver and
here black attacks the queen so he moves
the queen so the interesting thing is
that the Knight actually didn't get to
G5 until move 30 they made a bunch of
moves and only when nimsovich was ready
did he pave the way for the completion
of the maneuver which is really what
makes it so beautiful and then in this
position he makes another incredible
trading move Queen to E1 infiltrating
through the center
and now Bang and now bang on the other
side of the board the idea is to open up
a pathway for the bishop to D6 this is
just unbelievable chess and Rubenstein
another
giving away a piece because if he plays
a b then white just gets his Bishop
white just gets his Bishop into the game
via B4
Bishop before Bishop f8 like this just
look at these Maneuvers and you might
look at this and say why there's no way
I would ever find this just appreciate
it you know just enjoy it let this sink
in and you never know what kind of stuff
you will be able to find in the game so
this is where I drew the inspiration the
move Knight to H1 retreating night moves
are always fun to play
there's also simpler examples
it is white to play if you're watching
on YouTube pause for a bit see if you
can figure out what John Elvis played
the Estonian Grandmaster in this
position
well first to identify the weak Square
and the weak square is quite clear it's
it's D5 right this is the square is just
a huge weakness oftentimes when there's
a backward Pawn the square in front of
it is Prime real estate and the movies
that you guys are on a roll Knight's A1
everybody's fighting it and the Knight
is going in this case it went straight
to D5 like he didn't even care what
black was doing he went straight to D5
and remember I talked about how you want
to occupy a weak square with pieces
rather than pawns well
technically this is an exception to the
rule but here if black takes it white
simply wins a piece white simply wins a
piece white one's the night but here's
the thing black move the Knight
and then black moved the other night and
white still played A5 so you might say
well I learned that you know in this
case if I were to follow the rules black
would play Bishop takes D5 but this is
the concept of transforming your
advantage yes we've given up the monster
Knight on D5 yes the D5 square is no
longer weakness but white has gotten a
lot in return for that in particular
white has a fully improved Pawn
structure the pawns have gotten braces
in addition white gets a big diagonal
for this bishop in addition The Rook has
no squares in addition the pot on Z5
restricts the Black Knight so advantages
in chest positional advantages they
change hands a million times right and
the type of Advantage changes throughout
the game and you have to be ready and
willing in many cases to give up
something that you hold dear think in
literature there's the phrase Kill Your
Darlings where I think writers often
recommend to delete your favorite
sentences because you're emotionally
attached to them same thing with pieces
never giving away this night you have to
be ready to it's like a chemist pouring
stuff from one Beaker to another you got
to be ready to transform your advantage
so for instance here what I would do is
attack the B6 pawn and after Knight to
D7 I would say as a result of the move
CD you now have this move this move
threatens Bishop takes D7 and Rook takes
B6 and hopefully you can see how this is
kind of working
okay
one more example one from one of my
games in which I violated the rule about
not occupying a weak square with a pawn
but it I think illustrates another type
of exception to that rule
okay now this is a very primitive
example because the position in which
this example starts is already
completely winning and I don't like
examples like that because when you have
a completely winning position it it
dilutes the effectiveness of any any
given move but still I think you'll
appreciate this
still I think you'll appreciate this
here's a game that I played in 2006
um in the Pan American championships in
Ecuador and in this position I'm up upon
and I'm dominating my opponent just
played Knight takes C5 the E5 square is
sweet what did I take back with and most
importantly why
this is a classic example of
transforming your advantage of course I
took with the plot
positional rules would dictate that you
want to take with the queen but no I
took with the pawn what is the advantage
that I'm getting
I'm getting the D6 Square I'm simply
exchanging one weakness for another now
the D6 square is weak and I have just
the Machinery to put a rook on it rookie
E8 and I pre-moved Rook D6 and then I
doubled on the D file the other big
Advantage is that you get the D file
and I won very easily by snapping up
another Pawn in my opponent resign okay
so hopefully you're starting to
appreciate the the general concept here
all right
on we go to
the the speedrun game
okay so Knight B8 our opponent I think
makes another mistake not a big mistake
but I think after Bishop D3 the position
is officially lost I would say that if
if we had to draw kind of an arc of the
game I think after Bishop D3 Bishop F3
White's just got too many weaknesses I
ran this in the engine and very
interestingly white actually had a
chance to develop some serious counter
play and I saw this move but I didn't
fully appreciate it does anybody want to
take a guess
at what white should have done in this
position it's essentially the only thing
that white can do in order to gain
counter playing some of you are probably
thinking G4 this is not counter play
this just weakens your position even
further what does G4 do it's a one move
threat does it do anything our Bishop is
excellent on G6 you need to look at the
other side of the board muhammadov got
it the move is A4
and this looks like a crazy move because
black could just take a name for black
and just take on it for and it seems
like you can't take back because C2
Falls that's the whole point of our play
but as uh as often happens the engine
finds crazy ideas out of nowhere and
this is a perfect example after Queen
takes C2
white simply takes back this is like so
hard to understand white takes back
white plays Bishop to D3 and after Rook
C7 white plays this move Knight each and
apparently white is not that much worse
and the reason that white is not that
much worse is because this Knight is
coming to a monster Square on C5 once
the Knight lands on C5 we have a
weakness on A6 White's pieces are
actually quite nicely placed now and
Black's Advantage is greatly limited so
after A4 black actually should respond
and meet fire with fire the best move
here the way to keep an advantage is
Knight to E4 but after Knight take C4
Pawn take C4
white is supposed to go Knight G5
fearlessly and the position gets very
tactical very tactical and this is
exactly what you want if you're on the
defending side and you feel like you're
running out of chances this is why my
coach would always tell me and would
hammer this into my head make it
tactical right you feel like the game is
slipping away from you
even if it's unsound even if you feel
like now this this move has no chance of
working your opponent is going to be
uncomfortable if they suddenly have to
deal with a whole new set of challenges
they suddenly have to calculate they
suddenly have to worry about King safety
whereas earlier they were just chilling
enjoying complete positional domination
that is the underpinning of the move A4
it makes things tactical and you don't
need to calculate these moves out
completely so that makes sense I don't
want to get into the the weeds here you
can analyze this yourself with the
engine technically because of this
Knight V8 is an inaccuracy if White had
found
you know the insane move A4 but still I
like the idea from the standpoint of you
know positional mastery okay
so once our opponent missed this chance
and allowed Bishop three uh is that ship
has sailed I mean maybe white can play
A4 now
uh but but I don't think it's nearly as
effective I think after A4 here black
can just play Knight B6 anyway and uh
just get this Knight C4 and the point is
after Bishop C4 or queen C4 The Rook is
hanging and you will recapture the pawn
on B5 still I think white should have
played eight four still I think this is
essentially the only chance
um after white played Rook G1 we played
uh G6 still A4 right this just was a
move that our opponent wasn't looking
for right I don't think our opponent was
thinking that actually white is the one
who can develop counter play on The
Queen side because this B5 Pawn is a
serious weakness
our opponent played Knight E2 and now
the ship has officially sailed because
now A4 is no longer possible we simply
take on A4 and again the move that H5
what is the idea the idea is that the
Knight on the rim controls let's less
squares but it controls the important
squares it controls G3 and F4 and
thereby it restricts the Knight on E2
so the takeaway from this particular
situation is that you should never
assume that just because the Knight is
on the rim is bad in fact Knights on the
rim can be freaking fantastic if the
circumstances
um are right here is one final example
of a game in which a very strong GM
voluntarily brings the Knight
onto the rim and he does it in a style
that's very similar to what I did
here it is
this is the game ribbly against Larson
now generally Larson is on The Winning
Side of these types of game series on
the losing side who can find the pathway
that ribley took for his Knight and this
is easy because I've set you up for this
now day one another retreating night
move Knight C2 Knight A3 now look what
Larson did knightcc7 and here are very
instructive mistake would be to insist
on Knight B5 because here there is a
perfect example of where a weak square
is rendered inaccessible by the fact
that a pawn sits on it you're not
exploiting it and here blackened just
transition to counter play on the king
side so God forbid you don't go Knight
B5 here you sit on A3
what is the benefit of sitting on A3
well you have black completely tied down
anytime black moves this Knight away
from C7 you immediately jump into B5 so
yeah technically whitesnite only
controls two squares but it's still an
incredible night does that make sense
and eventually guess what happened
eventually Larson
he moves his night away
it happened many many moves later
and finally ribley eventually eventually
eventually
e what a night on B5 it was move 45 but
eventually it happened and that night
essentially won the game there were a
lot of inaccuracies along the way so I
won't analyze the game itself that's not
the important part hopefully that makes
sense
okay back we go to the game
and of course there was also the benefit
that we've opened up a pathway for our
Queen and that's exactly what we did F4
and queen to d8 preparing to go to H4
and now the cherry on top knight takes
F4 but actually tactically this is an
inaccuracy tactically it was a better
idea to start with this move and then
play Knight takes F4 and that is because
White had this crazy resource Knight to
F5 which is a movie you might be looking
at personally might be like I'm tired of
this game but you might be looking this
movement saying I don't get this move at
all what is it what are we what's
happening well it's a simple move to
understand actually it's much simpler
than it seems first of all for newer
players did we blunder a knight no
because here when H4 is a double attack
attacking the bishop and if the bishop
moves then you deliver a very powerful
Checkmate on H3 white is no way to
defend both at the same time essentially
the but uh what is the purpose of Knight
F5 who can explain this move in general
terms
how do you find a move like this pin so
first of all you're using the pin but
the basic idea is that you're forcing
black to play EF
because black does not have time for an
intermed cell if black takes the bishop
then you take the bishop and suddenly
everything is hanging
the point is that after e takes F5 you
play Bishop takes F4
first of all you've stopped this move
because now the bishop can block the
attack whereas if we compare this to um
this position the Knight is obstructing
the bishop so that's the kind of
tactical point of this move the
positional point of this move is that
after the trade you've gotten some
pieces off the board so why it's a
little bit less cramped Black's Pawn
structure has been damaged the D5 Fawn
is a weakness white is threatening
Bishop takes F5 and black still has
quite a bit of work to do king h8 black
is winning
but white at least can try to defend
you know you want to hear something
crazy you know what the engine proposes
in this position you'll never believe
this you know what the chest.com engine
proposes room shoe one to A1 and A4 so
this plan of A4 is still available for
white to generate counter play on The
Queen side which just shows you how
engines always aim for active counter
play that's like all they do
so this A4 Pawn lever you're never going
to forget but by the way if you're a
sicilian player each you shouldn't be
looking at this and saying oh this is
crazy because in the Sicilian and the
open system in the night or if this is
like one of the most standard ideas for
white if not the most standard so for
instance every Russian school boy knows
that in the night off you're not
supposed to play B5 too early okay
you're not supposed to play B5 too early
why who can tell me why
and this this will show me who's paying
attention
essentially and this actually happened
in one of my games
because of A4 exactly
and um I had a game just like this
I had a game just like this many years
ago
uh where my opponent it was about 1900
you know pretty good player but he he
did exactly that he played B5
prematurely and this is sillian my coach
had already taught me the importance of
chipping away at the pawn structure like
this and what ended up happening was
that immediately black started paying
the price because his pawns are now
disjointed and black can't rejoin them
because the B5 square is going to become
a massive weakness so my opponent ended
up giving away a bunch of squares and
his entire Queen side collapsed in a
matter of a couple of moves so this is
the concept of borrowing ideas from one
opening to the other you learn about A4
and the Sicilian you play it in a London
that's why people who are obsessed with
like okay this is the opening I have to
play I have to play it for the rest of
my life
chess is a universal language if you
build a solid foundation for yourself
where you understand
the sort of rudiments of positional play
and you collect a bunch of these ideas
you'll be able to play a lot of
different openings pretty decently you
might not know the details but you'll be
able to play it you'll be able to play
sound chess
okay and finally the home stretch of
this game
in the game our opponent missed this
idea which is totally understandable
Knight F5 is a very difficult move after
King H2 Queen H4 the game is totally
over now the game is over because we
have up upon a black is collapsing and
we open a second front with E5
we get the knife into the game
and now Rook C6 I think is a super
accurate move super accurate vote
because it keeps maximum flexibility and
it involves everybody it's better than
rookie 8 because if you play rookie like
wait what about the other Rook I guess
the other one could go to C8 but here
you have so many ideas you have the Rook
lift but you're also staying on the C
file so you're maintaining flexibility
and it came in handy it came in handy
because once white moved the bishop I
realized that wait a second now this
spot is weak you immediately switch to
the other side of the board
Queen 65 Rook d8 of course we could also
play Rook C2 it doesn't matter Rook
takes C2 and I am a little bit mad
because this was correct
the Knight is Untouchable F2 is hanging
white has to do this and I'm mad at
myself that I didn't play this move
because that F2 is just that name
and what I realized Consulting the
engine this is kind of what happened in
the game except it happened in a
different move order in this position
white actually has a move that I missed
white has an annoying move and that move
is a rook to G2 and the game actually
goes on I would not like to have this
against Magnus
because
black is up two pawns here but amazingly
it's actually not so easy to win this
because the A6 Pawn is a huge weakness
and White's Rook suddenly jumps into F6
and suddenly black is experiencing some
problems because you know you don't want
to go Rook A8 because then you're super
passive and you're tied down at this
Pawn
so it's a better idea for black to play
this move according to the engine and
essentially trade on Black's terms to
prevent the white Rook from getting to
the sixth rank but still you know
there's some technique left to show
completely winning position you're up
two pawns but the game would have
dragged on unnecessarily but I couldn't
resist I mean a queen sacrifice to top
off a game like this is you know it's
really really cool and as a nice detail
here you take the queen
you do I was considering this move
briefly but it doesn't work because the
Rook takes F2 and like Bishop G2
adult go too crazy with this
of course the idea is that this is
checkmate and that's how the game ended
only 35 moves on the shorter side but
such a rich game with so many different
stages right there was the theoretical
stage where we followed you know a super
important line of the London
then after White's first inaccuracy
the game entered a kind of
pre-positional stage where black is
completing their development and white
is starting to experience problems with
finding a plant
so the first serious mistake our
opponent made was Bishop E3 then our
opponent kind of let us improve our
position B4 was another mistake and then
I would say the decisive mistake was to
allow the ruining of the kingside pawn
structure after which White's position
is just falling apart of the sea at the
seams just too many weaknesses and we
were able to exploit them by playing out
all three sides of the board kingside
Center and then Queen side doubling on
the C file okay any questions folks
about this this game
um this was a very long Speed Run I
might break this up into two parts just
to milk a little bit more content off
this but
I hope that this wasn't you know too dry
and too technical
you know these kinds of games for me are
are important because I can pack a lot
of positional knowledge into my
explanations of these kinds of games and
I don't want to let that opportunity go
by because I know that I can really
Advance help Advance your your
positional Basics if I'm if I explain
the ideas well okay
thank you everybody
and thank you for those watching on
YouTube
I will go to sleep which I need to do
immediately
and I will see you guys later let me
raid one more thing folks if you're
watching and you're new to the channel
if you like what you see you feel like I
help you get better
you know obviously I
um appreciate all of the twitch support
and all of the subs
um but also the YouTube Subs are super
important for me particularly because I
fight the algorithm and I don't do
clickbait you know I do stuff that
actively makes the videos not get
recommended to people so if you want to
put a like
you sub to my YouTube channel you really
help me out I want to get to 500k at
some point in my lifetime
probably won't happen anytime soon but
every every sub really counts so thank
you
thank you everybody bye
foreign
[Music]